all right guys this is a very
important video i want to talk
about the absolute most important
thing you can do to prevent cancer
fasting fasting is hands down the most important
thing to do if you want to prevent cancer and if
you have cancer you need to be doing fasting
cancer is the second leading cause of death
so this is the protocol that i would recommend for
someone that is interested in preventing cancer
let's say for example your family has cancer or
your health is poor or you just want to prevent
cancer and you want to do something about it i
would recommend start on omed immediately that
means one meal a day okay so you're only going to
eat one meal a day in fact i recommend most people
do all that it's extremely easy to do you're going
to save a lot of money but it's very very powerful
to improve your health which i'm going to get to
in a minute so i would do omit on a regular basis
yeah and i recommend you do 48 hour fast weekly
now this is really good to do if you have extra
weight to lose to one and a half teaspoons of sea
salt every single day very important b vitamins
and trace minerals so i put a link down below if
you want more data on that but that protocol would
be very very important if you want to take it to
the next level and really help your immune system
every month you would do a seven day fast now
you might be freaked out to do that well fast as
long as you can maybe it's going to be three days
maybe four days and maybe you have to build up to
a seven day fast but if you did that you would put
yourself in really good shape to prevent cancer so
what i'm talking about is regular intermittent
fasting and periodic prolonged fasting
one video i did on the gentleman that had cancer
stage four cancer okay he did some serious fasting
and he was expected to die within a month it's
been two years he's doing great his doctor can't
find any cancer he did a lot of fasting he did
more intense fasting than what i'm talking about
but what i'm talking about is how to prevent
cancer okay so i'm not primarily talking about
people who already have cancer all right let's
talk about why fasting would help prevent cancer
first off it will help stop mtor okay what
is mtor mtor is something in your body
that allows things to grow okay it creates an
anabolic effect so when you fast you turn off
that effect so you can actually greatly inhibit
the growth of anything in your body okay it also
decreases igf which is another growth factor so
you're shutting down mtor and igf so that right
there is a powerful effect on cancer number two
autophagy autophagy is a condition where your
body is recycling the old damaged junk okay let's
say your mitochondria are damaged or you have dead
red blood cells your body is going to actually
clean all that up and since cancer originates with
damaged mitochondria if you can clean that
up there's not enough damaged mitochondria
to turn into cancer which then these cancer
cells become immortal which kind of sucks because
your cells have a time limit but cancer cells can
live forever all right number three you actually
generate brand new stem cells for your immune
system you're actually building a new immune
system and guess what your immune system not
only fights pathogens it kills cancer it kills
cancer cells on a regular basis so if you have
a powerful strong immune system you are very
protected number four fasting drops inflammation
what you have to realize is that when you have
a metastasis or a spreading of cancer guess where
it spreads into areas of inflammation interesting
even areas of old injury so by doing fasting you
just drop inflammation all right number five and
this pretty much pertains to someone that has
cancer and is on chemotherapy let's say they
decide to do chemotherapy or radiation therapy
fasting increases resistance for your normal cells
when they're exposed to chemotherapy and radiation
incredible but the cancer cells don't get that
resistance they're more sensitized to chemotherapy
and radiation therapy interesting all right so
what if you already have cancer okay i'm not going
to do a whole video on that but i want to give you
some tips on some natural things that i would
recommend and my disclaimer is i'm not telling
you this is going to cure anything check with
your doctor before taking anything okay alpha
lipoic acid 0.4 to 0.8 grams per day you start off
small amounts and you gradually increase over two
to three weeks okay next remedy would be garcinia
another name for garcinia is hydroxycitrate
between 1.2 to 3 grams start off with 1.2
gradually increase to 3 grams over to three weeks
this is per day next remedy is red algae okay
eight grams per day next remedy is black seed oil
you can get in 500 milligrams twice a day consume
a lot of garlic if you can't eat garlic take them
in tablets a lot of garlic is very very important
next remedy is green tea you can also get this as
a supplement or consume it through the day and
lastly you want to consume a lot of cruciferous
vegetables the broccoli sprouts would be very
very important as well because it's a very
small amount of those broccoli sprouts equal a
tremendous amount of adult broccoli all right
guys thanks for watching hey before you go real
quick i have a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i want
you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone is
focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today